verde
aquí en Antioquia más de 130 horas
después del terremoto
cuando los rescatistas corren significa
una cosa Hay una oportunidad de vida
bajo los escombros un bebé ha sido
encontrado
[Aplausos]
no tarda en llegar la noticia a las
familias de los que vivían aquí
[Música]
tras horas bajo tierra emergen los
rescatistas cubiertos de polvo han
intentado extraer a una familia de cinco
personas atrapada en el segundo piso
tiene un video grabado hace unos minutos
[Música]
para esta afligida tía llega la
confirmación por fin de que su sobrina
llamada ligue de un año se ha salvado
[Música]
tras una agónica espera en silencio por
el momento no se detecta nadie más
los tíos de aliye se dirigen al hospital
en helicóptero la búsqueda continúa
hasta tarde solo interrumpida brevemente
por una réplica
Pero al final llega la confirmación los
familiares directos de aliye no
sobrevivieron
[Música]
es un bebé milagro una sobreviviente de
uno de los momentos más oscuros de
Turquía